bonsoir pierre logerinel premier adjoint
udia morpa également je le disais
représentant de l'UDI dans le
département vous en êtes le
vice-président l'UDI des yelines qui
s'est doté aussi d'un président ce
weekend Arnaud Richard député de la 7e
circonscription a été élu avec 97 % des
suffrages on va forcément y revenir
auparavant on va évoquer la situation
dans votre commune le maire George
Mougeot d'ver gauche qui ne siège plus
actuellement pour des raisons de santé
il a d'ailleurs précisé lors de son
dernier éditorial dans le journal
municipal en écrivant qu'il était
convalescent après une importante
intervention chirurgicale cela veut dire
aujourd'hui Pierre Le guerinel que les
affaires de la ville sont bloquées ou
alors que vous prenez toutes les
décisions comment fonctionne la ville
aujourd'hui mais c'est bien plus simple
que ça d'abord c'est une situation que
chacun aurait souhaité éviter pour des
raisons personnelles que vous imaginez
bien George moujot a eu le courage
d'être transparent ce qui est à signaler
il a dit clairement les choses tous les
propos que vous vous venez d'indiquer
son lescien ils sont tous exacts alors
est-ce que ça change fondamentalement
les choses si j'en crois au fond
quelques habitants interroger pas
vraiment certains ne le savaient même
pas ce qui est plutôt rassurant est-ce
que ça veut dire qu'onexpédie que les
affaires courantes la réponse est non
est-ce que ça veut dire qu'on prend des
décisions importantes la réponse est non
pour une raison simple c'est qu'en cas
de d'empêchement de vacances de l'élu
qui a été choisi par le conseil
municipal comme maire la loi exige qu'il
y ait un remplaçant pour que les actes
pris soient valides donc qu'il donne une
délégation pour une durée qui est
variable donc c'est dans ce cadre que
nous situons donc on va dire que la
délégation fait qu'il y a un maire
juridique mais il n'y a pas un maire
politique le Maur politique reste
évidemment George moujant on va revenir
he tout à tout à fait sur cette
évolution pour être bien précis pour les
administrés de la ville qui se demander
un petit peu aussi quand on va revenir
le maire auparavant un exemple concret
qui est aussi lié à l'actualité sur le
le fonctionnement sur l'actualité autour
de la ville de de morpa morpa la
verrière coignère et hlencour qui
s'unissent dans leur contestation avec
pour porte-parole d'ailleurs votre
adjoint au trava bra une lettre ouverte
à Guillaume pépil président de la SNCF
va être envoyée les voyageurs de la gare
de La Verrière vont pouvoir demain
signer cette lettre ouverte pour faire
pression afin d'obtenir une
programmation de mise en orbord
d'accessibilité rénovation complète
également du site rétablissement de
vente des billets grandes lignes
installation d'automate prolongement
aussi avant 2020 de la ligne C du RER
donc jusqu'à coignère il y a beaucoup de
contestations autour de ce site de La
Verrière c'est un dossier important vous
le suivez oui et d'ailleurs je trouve
très bien que en dépit de leur
différence de point de vue politique les
maires des communes les plus concernées
et accepté de s'unir dans cette affaire
puisqu'il y aura les représentants de la
verrière et de morpac sont les deux
communes les plus directement
intéressées mais il y aura aussi la
municipalité d'élancours et celle de
coignère écoutez il y a un moment il
faut dire les choses on se moque de nous
ça suffit j'ai assisté à une réunion
technique il y a quelques semaines dans
un brillant aréopage où le représentant
de la CNCF à titre personnel je lui en
veux pas évidemment mais venez nous
expliquer expliquit gentiment qu'il y
aurait un début de travaux que tout ça
était prévu en 2019 donc je pense qu'on
se moque clairement du monde demander
aux gens qui prennent le train j'en suis
mais qui parfois sont handicapés qui ont
une mobilité réduite qui ont des
poussettes des bagages comment ils
arrivent à passer sur les quis quand il
pleut pourquoi ils doivent patoger dans
l'eau et alors c'est non mais il y a eu
quelques travaux mineurs faits il y a
quelques semaines comme par hasard on
nous a refait un bout d'escalier qui
d'ailleurs est déjà en train de
s'effriter donc ça va quoi ça va bien
donc les élus vont manifester leur
colère plus que leur mécontentement leur
colère pour dire à Monsieur Pépi il y a
pas que les grandes lignes de TGV qui
comptent pour le transport des gens et
dans la région parisienne d'ailleurs pas
que Guillaume Pépi il y a aussi le sttif
pour la part l'autre partie
mais exemp j'ai été conseiller régional
j'ai commencé mon mandat en 2004 depuis
2004 j'entends exactement la même
chanson même si j'avais mauvaise mémoire
je finiraai par retenir le refrain ne
vous inquiétez pas nous ferons des
travaux oui quand 2019 c'est totalement
déraisonnable voilà donc on va le dire
et on aura l'occasion de revenir sur ce
ce dossier don nous en parlerons demain
en plateau on revient juste sur ce sur
cette situation actuelle dans cette
ville de morpa vous siégez en
remplacement donc du maire qui est en
convalescence actuellement dans votre
opposition tout de même il se dit que
c'est un peu particulier parce que vous
êtes udi que le maire est plutôt divver
gauche que la majorité plutôt socialiste
comment se passe la cohabitation ça
c'est une grande découverte et ben c'est
pas une découverte mais comment se passe
la cohabitation par cont écoutez jusqu'à
preuve du contraire ça se passe bien
pour une bonne raison c'est que alors
d'abord l'UDI n'a pas de gr vis-à-vis de
George Mougeot au contraire moi j'estime
d'abord à titre personnel que c'est un
maire qui par l'ancienneté qu'il a dans
cette ville a témoigné qu'il avait fait
des choses et des choses dont je salue
la présence il les a faites et plutôt
bien faites bon vient évidemment un jour
où il faut que les choses passent dans
d'autres mains bah ce jour-là nous
verrons bien moi j'ai fait une alliance
avec George Mougeot sur la base d'un
projet et c'est avec George moujot que
je l'ai fait donc ce projet arrive à son
terme parce que nous sommes
objectivement en fin de mandat c'est
pour ça qu'il y a pas de grandes
opération nouvelle à mettre en œuvre
donc vu de mon côté il n'y a pas de
problème si d'ailleurs il y en avait un
le maire je pense saurait me le dire et
nous en expliquerions pour en tirer
toutes les conséquences mais je ne vois
pas en quoi cette situation pourrait
aujourd'hui intervenir vous connaissez
la date de retour du maire George
mou non non mais il l'a dit il a dit
dans les quelques semaines qui viennent
je pense que ce sera le cas et d'abord
évidemment je le souhaite on va parler
des municipales parce que vous nous
l'avez dit nous sommes en fin de mandat
il y a forcément des municipales l'année
prochaine auparavant un micro trottoir
vous constatez l'absence de votre mère à
morpa et que pensez-vous de cette
situation non je n'en sais rien ça me
fait rien à partir du moment où je pars
enfin il a une équipe il est pas tout
seul donc logiquement même en son
absence et il a le droit d'être malade
le pauvre il y a l'équipe tourne quand
même et j'ai confiance alors j'ai j'ai
appris ça tout il y a quelques temps de
cela effectivement qu'il était qu'il
était souffrant qu'il en convalesence
c'est sûr que un M c'est quand même
important dans une ville surtout une
ville qui est dynamique comme celle de
morpa donc effectivement ça manque bon
on sait qu'elle fonctionne quand même la
mairie
mais un mer c'est quand même important
oui parce que j'ai lu ça sur l'bdom
enfin le journal ne Mor pas à mon avis
ça change rien mais j'espère que le
prochain fera plus de choses à Mor pas
est-ce que ça m'inquiète ben c'est
toujours inquiétant de savoir quand
quelqu'un est pas en bonne santé mais
au-delà de ça il y a peut-être un moment
il faut savoir laisser la place aux
autres on sait même pas si'il est là ou
il est pas là parce que ça change rien
la vie continue à mort pas mais on sait
que ce remplaçant monsieur Guinel on
entend un petit peu parler de lui ça va
la vie se poursuit à mortp voilà les
choses se continuent se poursuivent et
donc ça n'inquiète pas la population par
contre dans le micro trottoir on s'est
aussi posé la la question de l'après
George Mougeot George Mougeot est ma
depuis 1989 est-ce que vous pensez qu'il
devrait se présenter à nouveau pour un
5e mandat attendez d'abord je pense
qu'il y a des questions qu'il faut poser
directement aux intéressés je peux aussi
vous poser la question puisque vous êtes
premier adjoint est-ce qu'il devrait se
présenter à nouveau en tout cas est-ce
que s'il se présente à nouveau et qu'il
vous propose de rejoindre une fois de
plus sa liste vous le rejoindrez c'est
une question qui se discutera entre lui
et moi d' c'est une question qui n'a pas
encore eu lieu non bien sûr que non bien
sûr que non si elle avait eu lieu je
pense que d'une manière ou d'une autre
vous le sauriiez déjà vous êtes
journaliste on pose aussi la question au
principaux intéressés pour vérifier les
informations et c'est pour ça que vous
la POS discussion n'a pas eu lieu George
mjot a dit clairement lors des vœux de
décembre de cette année qu'il dirait ce
qu'il fera le moment venu voilà c'est
lui qui décide du moment c'est pas aux
autres de le bousculer certains par
amitié d'autres par amitié calculé c'est
lui qui décide et vous vous
positionnerez à ce moment-là une fois
que George m aura fait les annonces
qu'il a à faire vous vous
positionnerez les morpadiiens que vous
avez interrogé il viennent de vous
donner une réponse intéressante d'abord
ils sont pas plus spécialement inquiets
que ça mais ils ont dit dans le même
temps qu'un maire ça compte ça veut dire
qu'un maire c'est pas une élection
municipale c'est pas n'importe quelle
élection si vous souvenez de Gaulle qui
parlait les années 60 les gens qui
parlent de l'Europe en créant comme des
Cabril l'Europe l'Europe bon et ben
c'est pas je veux être maire je veux
être maire c'est un peu plus compliqué
il faut réunir une équipe il faut un
vrai projet il faut une dynamique il
faut écouter des gens il faut c'est pas
seulement j'ai envie d'exister je vous
poser la question différemment vous êtes
vice-président de l'UDI également siégé
en tant que que premier adjoint udi
est-ce que l'UDI fera une alliance
quelconque que ce soit avec l'UMP que ce
soit avec un un divers gauche puisque
gen moujot n'est pas au Parti socialiste
même si sa majorité est socialiste qui
complique peut-être un peu les choses
sur la commune pas intégralement hein
pas du tout est-ce queudi comment l'UDI
peut se positionner comment vous
imaginez le positionnement de l'UDI en
tout cas sur cette ville et bien écoutez
ça me donnera le plaisir de vous revoir
vous me rzinvitez quand le bureau de
l'UDI se sera réuni pour la première
fois c'estàdire dans quelques jours et
là vous aurez la réponse vous imaginez
quoi une position quand même de de l'UD
vous devez forcément avoir une idée
l'UDI pourrait faire alliance pas
alliance comment vous voyez l'UDI en
tout cas parce que l'UDI au niveau
national on nous explique aussi que
c'est un parti d'alliance avec l'UMP
alors l'UDI à l'échelle nationale a
choisi une option préférentielle en
disant pour éviter de tomber dans dans
le travers mais que j'ai euh connu
pendant de longues années c'est celui du
MoDem disant c'est pas trop vous êtes
est-ce que c'est une meilleure position
bah les résultats le diront bon euh
l'UDI moi j'entends dans udi union des
démocrates indépendants h bon alors il y
aura forcément une union nous serons de
démocrates et je tiens à rester
indépendant donc vous positionnerez pas
forcément en fonction de la ligne de
l'UDI vous ferez vos propres choix nous
nous déciderons ensemble de la meilleure
façon d'étendre notre capacité à agir HM
voilà il y a des gens qui ne voient
qu'en terme d'influence de maintien de
situations acquises nous ce qui nous
intéresse c'est de développer des
projets non justement les projets quel
est l'enjeu autour de cette ville de
morpa par la suite parce qu'on voit
qu'il y a beaucoup de gens qui sont
intéressés juste pour revenir sur ces
candidatures parce qu'on ne sait pas
pour l'UDI vous nous le direz on
l'espère en avant-première sur ce
plateau ensuite sur votre position voilà
George mougeon on ne sait pas s'il se
représentera du côté du Parti socialiste
on évoque aussi une candidature en tout
cas il est candidat à l'investiture Isma
avan le conseiller général de de ce
canton il y a beaucoup de gens qui se
positionnent en tout cas déjà ne en
coulisse quel est l'enjeu autour de
cette ville de morpa je crois que
l'enjeu en tout cas si on veut bien
comprendre ce dont cette ville a besoin
c'est qu'elle a besoin d'une évolution
et pas d'une révolution elle a besoin de
conserver un cadre de vie que j'ai
découvert il y a des années je m'y suis
installé j'y vis maintenant depuis des
années Mor pas une chance assez
extraordinaire c'est quand on traverse
la nationale 10 on y voit au fond une
bande d'habitat qui ne donne pas la
réalité de cette ville cette ville elle
a besoin de conserver sa tranquillité
dans un cadre qui va être difficile dans
les années à venir chacun c'est bien la
crise est loin d'être terminée les
communes devront de plus en plus assumer
le lien social le développement de
l'emploi la capacité associative donc il
va falloir des gens qui a un peu de
sérénité c'est pas la peine de se
bousculer au portillon à mon avis un peu
d'expérience soit pas tous des chiens
fous et qui sacheent quels sont très
exactement les enjeux majeurs moi je
pense que l'enjeu il se résume à ça il
faut du dynamisme et en même temps
n'effrayer personne il y a aucune raison
d'effrayer les gens écoutez je pense
qu'on vit dans un environnement qui est
assez stressant comme ça c'est pas la
peine d'en rajouter vous sentez vous
donnez le sentiment d'avoir un projet
pour cette ville de morpa ça veut dire
que vous avez déjà pensé à une liste
pour mener ça pour proposer ce projet
j'ai pensé à aller interroger des gens
qui peuvent être intéressés pour se
coaliser se fédérer et fabriquer cette
union dont je pense que nous aurons
évidemment besoin un jour c'est aussi
simple que ça pour continuer une
dernière question qui concerne l'UDI
vous nous l'avez dit l'UDI se structure
récemment on a parlé également sur cette
antenne de la création d'une fédération
de de jeunes l'UDI aujourd'hui pourrait
se tourner aussi vers le modem absorber
le modem vous qui venez du MoDem
justement bah écoutez moi je suis pas
dans le secret mais j'ai par j'ai
parfois entendu j'ai parfois entendu
Jean-Louis borlot dire que pour sa part
il n'y verrait pas forcément
d'inconvénient simplement pour pas faire
référence à un débat ooule est récent
quand on décide d'union il vaut mieux
être deux faut que les deux soient
d'accord en tout cas la porte est
ouverte à l'UDI ah mais je pense qu'à
l'UDI la porte est fermée à très peu de
gens vous savez en dehors des mouvements
extrémistes qui éissent le poil de tout
républicain je vois pas pourquoi
d'avance il faudrait fermer les portes
pierre leerinet le premier adjoint maire
de morpa été l'invité du début de cette
édition du du 78 pour ceux qui
viendraient de nous rejoindre vous
pouvez également revoir cette
intervention sur le replay gratuitement
sur notre site internet dès demain matin
puisqu'on parle politique juste une
dernière information avec cette
cantonnale partielle du 30 juin à Mantel
jolie le dépôt des candidatures qui est
maintenant terminé se présente donc
devant les électeurs Pierre Bédier avec
l'investiture UMP Nathalie Coste divers
gauche marque jamais pour le parti
communiste Cyril note pour le Front
national ramassal pour le Parti
socialiste et Christophe Scotti pour qui
est sans étiquette tout simplement voilà
pour les candidats et ils sont nombreux
sur cette cantonale partielle juste
peut-être votre réaction sur la
situation de Pierre Bédier qui a purgé
sa peine d'inéligibilité qui se
représente devant les électeurs c'est
l'ancien président du du conseil général
d'ailleurs vous en pensez quoi mais que
d'abord c'est un problème qui concerne
l'UMP pas l'UDI mais vous en tant que
politique quel regard vous pouvez avoir
deuxième chose j'entends beaucoup de
choses et j'invite quelquesuns à balayer
devant leurs porte on va pas faire le
tour de ceux qui ont des casseroles
par-ci par là dernière chose alors moi
je suis très légaliste çave j'ai pas
fait du droit pendant longtemps pour
rien c'est quand la loi est passée c'est
la loi toute la loi rien que la loi si
les gens sont blanchis moi je ne me sens
pas habilité à dire qu'ils ne doivent
pas s'ils ne sont pas blanchis je ne
comprends pas qu'ils aient des vités de
vouloir revenir alors c'est pas blanchi
he c'est mais en tout cas en terme de
loi il a purgé sa peine il agé sa peine
donc il prend ses responsabilités
maintenant la seule sanction qui vaut en
démocratie elle est simple c'est qui
votera et pour qui voteront ceux qui
iront se déplacer vers les ures et on
aura le résultat dans pas très longtemps
le 30 juin on pourra faire le point
justement merci Pierre learinel d'être
venu sur ce plateau et on vous attend
pour parler de la suite des municipales
notamment dès que les annonces pouront
êre faites